what is a lock-up period entrepreneurs
like the cofounders of Twitter are in
the business of starting companies
growing companies taking those companies
public with an IPO and then becoming
billionaires overnight right well not
quite
when a company shares are initially sold
on the open market the founders and
employees cannot sell their personal
shares for a stretch of time typically 3
or 6 months this is known as the lock-up
period and it's put in place to prevent
large shareholders from flooding the
market and thus depressing the price
it's that old supply and demand law but
there's another slightly less obvious
reason for these lock ups
if a company founder were to cash out as
soon as possible
ie the day the IPO that would hardly
fill the share buying public with much
enthusiasm for the company's future
earnings potential and if you've started
grown and taken your company public
you've probably got a little more faith
in whatever it is you're selling and so
selling those shares can wait a little
longer